вітаємо всіх учасників нашої зустрічі
яка відбувається в рамках міжнародної
серпневої педагогічної
науково-практичної конференції освіта
освітяни Незламні у війні на шляху до
нашої Перемоги ми готові впевнено та
гідно прийняти виклики сьогодення бо
наша цінність і сила полягає в тому що
ми вже знаємо вже вміємо та маємо досвід
успішного подолання викликів тому Хочу
зазначити що сьогодні разом з нами
одночасно працюють колеги з інших сфери
освіти на 12 локаціях а назва власне
нашої локації це повертаємось до
навчання і під час нашого спілкування ми
спробуємо окреслити напрямки організації
шляхи реалізації освітнього процесу в
закладах загальної середньої освіти
приємно зазначити що разом зібралися
спільноти однодумців та партнерів які
готові разом взаємодіяти і надавати один
одному взаємопідтримку на шляху
відновлення навчання
2022-2023 навчального року і я пропоную
зараз так щоб це була зустріч така
дійсно неформальна розпочати її
знайомства Як то кажуть по колу і потім
ми
будемо слухати один одного вже залежно
від того плану який ми собі окреслили
тому Дозвольте за приклад представитися
Мене звати Катерина Павленко Я начальник
відділу культури гостомельської селищної
ради вчитель не колишній а теперішній
також тому мені дуже приємно бути разом
із вами
Оксана Коваленко головний спеціаліст
директорату дошкільної шкільної
позашкільної та інклюзивної освіти
а відповідає за іноземні мови за
дистанційну освіту і за все решту все що
пов'язано з міжнародною діяльністю
Тетяна Балашова керівник експертної
групи з питань шкільної освіти директора
та дошкільної дошкільної позашкільної та
інклюзивної освіти міністерства
Олександр кіненко директора державного
ліцею міжнародна українська школа
учитель української мови та літератури
Маргарита Носкова доцент кафедри
педагогіки інноваційної освіти директор
центру інноваційно-просвітньої
технології Національного університету
Львівська політехніка керівник
української дистанційної школи Галина
арсеменко начальник відділу організації
масових заходів
аналітична інформаційної роботи
інституту модернізації змісту освіти
Юрій Демидюк керівник українського
інституту розвитку освіти Ольга Донецька
європейський центр імені маргода
програма демократична школа Дарина сірук
керівник з розвитку
Наталія Бондарець очолює Київський
обласний інститут післядипломної освіти
педагогічних кадрів Сергій колобошин
заступник голови комітету Верховної Ради
з питань освіти новокриновації народних
депутатів вчителів фізики
е-е Олег топузов директор інституту
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України віце-президент академії
Роман Шиян заступник директора команди
підтримки реформи Міністерства освіти і
науки України складає українські школи
пілотних класів та побудового предмету
як природничі дякую дякую дуже приємна
команда фахова і тому я хочу
запропонувати розпочати наш зустріч
Сергія колибашина хороша Дякую спробую
швидко
мені насправді по-перше приємно тут
знаходитись нам же ж важлива в усьому
точку відліку не тільки в фізиці якщо
мене там три роки тому Ну запросили і
поставили запитання як ми входимо в
навчальний рік Я мабуть не знаючи
контексту того що відбувається
відбувалося в світі і в нас в державі Ну
схопився за голову Да що взагалі така
але якщо б ми це питання поставили один
одному Мені принаймні на кінці лютого на
початку березня то я мабуть би спитав
взагалі про що ми говоримо про який
навчальний рік
І що взагалі відбувається
але зараз дуже чудово що ми тут
знаходимось що ми усміхаємось що ми
радіємо зустріч один з одним і радіємо
зустрічі з учнями яка Я впевнений буде 1
вересня десь офлайні десь в онлайні Але
тим не менше вона буде
це супер вчора в нас було засідання
комітету де Міністерства зокрема
розповідала про
стан підготовки стан входження в новий
навчальний рік і я теж зауважив мені
було трохи ну не прикро а не зрозуміло
чому в доповіді ми торкнулися тільки
безпекової компоненти безумовно зараз
мабуть Найбільш важливою безпекою
компонентою компоненти пов'язана з
життями здоров'ям але нічого в звіті не
було про саме Ну сутність того що
відбувається в школі в нас з моєю точки
зору критично важливий рік просто
критично важливий рік з точки зору
впровадження і того що ми робимо з новою
українською школою ми всі входимо в
п'ятий клас базову загальну середню
освіту і якщо ми цей процес відпустимо
або номінально тобто в звітах Я розумію
що всі можуть написати що все добре І
так далі але номінально то це будуть
втрати ну з моєї точки зору невід
кислотні не тільки з точки зору того
скільки держави ресурсу вкладала
попередні роки а це ну мільярди і
десятки мільярдів гривень а й з точки
зору того як ця реформа сприймається в
суспільстві батьками учнями вчительством
і з точки зору ну майбутнього нашої
держави насправді того яким буде
громадянин нашої держави Ну як він буде
відповідати викликам сьогодення і тим
які стосуються нашої держави тим які в
світі
саме тому супер важливо що ми от зараз
тут всі локації ми будемо проговорювати
обговорювати ну здебільшого Саме ці
питання хоча знову повторюсь зараз в цей
рік в ці дні безпекова компонента Мабуть
таки да є важливою найважливішою тим не
менше Я абсолютно впевнений
в нашій перемозі в Збройних Силах і в
тому що ми в якості пріоритета рано чи
пізно будемо розглядати саме змістовну
компоненту освіти і оце от дискусія яка
в нас тут буде вона саме про це в цьому
сенсі я всім бажаю плідного обміну
думками я всіх ще раз Поздоровляю з
початком навчального року і слава
Україні слава за село Дякую
пане Сергію Ну що ж ми тоді пропонуємо
продовжити дійсно нашу зустріч а обмін
досвідом і до слова Я запрошую Тетяну
балашову Дякую
пан Сергій е мабуть найголовніше в цьому
найголовніший виклик цього навчального
року це як організувати освітній процес
та й в умовах які склалися зрозуміло що
вже певний досвід є
він
напрацьовувався
попри всі виклики які при цьому виникали
в складних умовах тому що складніших
умов чим військово-воєнний стан бути
просто не може і чим війна але
навчальний рік завершився діти отримали
документи про освіту діти змогли
вступати до закладів вищої освіти тобто
система освіти
створила такий прецедент який
Важко уявити але він є І це наш досвід
він болючий але він є
зараз У нас інший виклик тому що ми
маємо розпочати навчальний рік розпочати
навчальний рік І саме головне щоб цей
рік був для наших дітей педагогічних
працівників безпечним безпека понад усе
це
важливо мабуть в певній мірі це
важливіше ніж Сам той освітній процес
який має розпочатися має бути безпека
тому у міністерстві робоча група і
команда Міністерства напрацьовувала ті
моделі які можуть бути
реалізований в цьому навчальному році
виходили від чого від того що у нас є
дитина яка має здобувати освіту в
залежності від того де перебуває Ця
дитина таким може бути
модель організації освітнього процесу Чи
це дитина знаходиться у безпечному місці
важко говорити в Україні де це місце
безпечне але будемо вважати що є
території де є ще певний рівень безпеки
коли дитина є внутрішньо переміщеною
особою чи дитина знаходиться на
тимчасово окупованій території або за
кордоном враховуючи
умовний поділ наших здобувачів освіти на
ці Чотири категорії фактично ми можемо
говорити як для цих дітей може
організовуватися освітній процес
дитина знаходиться в Україні
там де вона проживала
як можна організувати освітній процес
звичайно зараз всі
освітяни засновники закладів освіти
працюють над тим щоб на таких територіях
освітній процес був учнем
викликів багато їх долають в першу чергу
це мають бути укриття тому що укриття
місткість укриттів дає можливість нам
організувати цей освітній процес очно в
залежності від того яке в нас яка
містить укриття це може бути одна зміна
двозмінне або інша Інша форма освіти
може бути звичайно ж дистанційна освіта
у закладах освіти за місцем проживання
цієї дитини чи в інших закладах сімейна
форма за вибором батьків може бути
змішана форма це коли ми говоримо про те
що
поєднується декілька
очноформа з використанням технології
дистанційної освіти Ну і звичайно ж
екстернат
якщо якщо ми говоримо про про внутрішньо
переміщених осіб то звичайно ж Діти теж
можуть здобувати освіти очно у тих
закладах освіти на території перебування
але ж зрозуміло що
на цих територіях виникають свої виклики
тому що є свої діти які там навчалися
потрібно створювати додаткові класи
організовувати змінність навчання але
така можливість є
дистанційна форма освіти тут теж
декілька
моделей або подій розвитку подій це може
бути на своєму закладі який залишився
заклад територіального приміщення там
але колектив
організовує освітній процес це може бути
заклад на території перебування теж
дистанційно Ну і звичайно ж як і для
кожної сімейна форма в нас фактично є
той універсальною формою На жаль Можливо
так сказати але вона дає можливість
добувати
освіту кожній нашій дитині змішана форма
і екстернат
якщо наш якщо ми говоримо про тимчасово
окуповані території це мабуть
найскладніший і
найболючіший виклик для системи освіти
як організувати тим дітям які опинилися
в таких складних умовах ми говоримо про
дистанційну форму або екстернат але тоже
Теж у дистанційному форматі ми говоримо
про сімейну домашню форму і звичайно ж
екстернат наражати на небезпеку наших
дітей Ми звичайно ж не можемо Враховуючи
те що із
дистанційною формою можуть бути певні
проблеми враховуючи наявність інтернету
враховуючи наявність гаджетів і
можливості підключення то найчастіше це
може бути самий наш звичайний
екстренатна форма і сімейна або домашня
якщо в нас дитина перебуває за кордоном
наших дітей дуже багато закордоном і це
теж виклик який потрібно вирішувати
в цьому навчальному році міністерством
підготовлено листи для всіх міністрів
освіти країн перебування
наших дітей з тим щоб вони сприяли
організації освітнього процесу і
здобуттю освіти саме за українськими
державними стандартами тому що є ряд
країн яких
дається можливість і є обов'язком
здобувати освіту саме в їхніх закладах
освіти тому для таких дітей звичайно ж
може бути очна форма Але
у закладах освіти країни перебуває це
може бути дистанційна форма навчання у
закладах освіти в Україні за нашими
державними стандартами це може бути
міжнародна українська школа це можуть
бути де дистанційні школи приватні які
допомагали
у цьому питанні дітям які перебували за
кордоном сімейна домашня і екстернат
тобто
фактично
організувати освітній процес Можливо але
кожна ця модель має свої
такі
особливості які потрібно вирішувати які
потрібно враховувати при організації
освітнього процесу але наша система
освіти мені сподобалося Катерина нам
робила вступ і говорила що ми маємо
досвід ми вже маємо досвід реагувати на
такі виклики і я впевнена що
1 вересня у наших школах розпочнеться
Я дуже радію що в нас наші діти зможуть
здобувати освіту очно А всі діти будуть
мати доступ до освіти а освітяни наші
докладуть максимум зусиль щоб ця освіта
була якісною дякую дякую
Я пропоную якщо будуть питання Потім
один голодного можливо до занотуєте і
потім після виступів ми тоді можемо
задати їх і почути відповіді ну а зараз
до слова Я запрошую Олександру кі
Доброго дня шановні колеги Доброго дня
друзі
насправді
міжнародна українська школа Стала такою
парасолькою яка об'єднала багатьох наших
громадян України які перебувають за
кордоном І власне історія проекту
міжнародна українська школа сягає ще
2005 року коли
самий громадські організації Греції
Іспанії Португалії звернулися з таким
запитом необхідності розвитку
Української освіти за кордоном до
Міністерства освіти до Міністерства
закордонних справ І власне в 2007 році
за ініціативи Міністерства освіти
кабінет міністрів рішення про створення
такого закладу освіти місія нашого
закладу
реалізація права на здобуття якісної
освіти громадян України який перебувають
за кордоном та в автономній республі
Крим після анексії Криму в 14-му році
нам додали ще цю категорію цю категорію
діток
власне структура міжнародної української
школи полягає в надання освіти як
початкової як базової так і профільної
повної освіти
ліцензійний обсяг здобувачів освіти
наших сягает 3 500 дітей станом на
сьогодні заклад налічує
3379 дітей за основними двома напрямками
А це у нас екстерни діти які готуються
до оцінювання та атестації за
індивідуальним навчальним планом за
допомогою методистів міжнародної
української школи і екстерни які
проходять підготовку до оцінювання та
атестації при освітніх центрах які
власне працюють при громадських
організаціях за кордоном і з цим
громадськими організаціями як юридичними
особами ми укладаємо договір про
співпрацю
за підсумками 21-22 навчального року ми
уклали договір з 30 з 37
громадським організаціями і при них
діють власне 40 отаких освітніх центрів
це можуть бути як і п'ятиденні школи так
і суботні і недільні школи
п'ятиденні школи у нас наразі діють в
Стамбулі у Варшаві і діє школа
новоутворена школа у Вільнюсі
географія наших всіх діток
налічує більш ніж 90 країн світу а
організації
школи-партнери у нас є в таких країнах
як Литва Франція Бельгія Греція Австрія
Чехія Італія Іспанія Португалія Молдова
от найбільш у нас дітей в Іспанії більше
е більше більше тисячі дітей
освітній процес загалом забезпечує
станом на сьогодні 35 педагогічних
працівників основних педагогічних
працівників міжнародної школи і 37
вчителів які працюють за сумісництвом
свідоцтво про здобуття базової освіти в
цьому році отримали 296 екстернів
свідоцтво про здобуття повної загальної
середньої освіти отримали 288 експерт
після 24 лютого
школа працює в посиленому режимі
більшість працівників Скажімо так
постійно
працювали з першого дня війни проводячи
оцінювання і надаючи консультації нашим
дітям які перебувають за кордоном
вчителі перебували як і за кордоном так
і по всій Україні так і в місті Києві І
власне в цьому році Нам вдалося завдяки
міністерству освіти
провести очне оцінювання екстернів шкіл
шкіл партнерів освітніх центрів
партнерів за допомогою Міністерства
закордонних справ за допомогою
дипломатичних установ тих країн шкіл
партнерів ми змогли виконати свою місію
і діти отримали документи про освіту
два напрямки які діють у нас в школі за
якими ми працюємо це власне екстернат
індивідуальний тобто дітки у нас
працюють за індивідуальним навчальним
планом у кожного є свій персональний
електронний кабінет через який власне
відбувається всякомунікація методисти і
вчителі школи надають як інформаційний
консультативний методичний супровід
організаційний супровід обов'язково для
таких категорій дітей великий
обсяг роботи у нас складають співпраця з
нашими освітніми центрами громадськими
організаціями за кордоном наразі наразі
така співпраця У нас діє через укладання
договорів про співпрацю з юридичними
особами громадськими організаціями
власне Також ми надаємо
інформаційну консультативну методичну
підтримку мене надаємо методичний
супровід вчителям які працюють в цих
освітніх центрах і готують діток до
оцінювання та атестації
що що стосується власне той необхідної
трансформації яка
покликана викликами і
пандемії і війни
на сьогодні міжнародна українська школа
трансформована вона змінила тип і назву
на сьогодні ми державний ліцей
народна українська школа зараз
проходимо процедуру затвердження
статутних документів щоб в повному
обсязі змогли реалізувати ті цілі А які
перед нами зараз стоять
наразі Ми плануємо продовжувати
продовжувати
екстренатну форму навчання наших діток
за індивідуальним навчальним планом Ми
продовжуємо співпрацю з громадськими
організаціями за кордоном
на сьогодні є великий запит багато
Запитів точніше від новостворених
громадських організацій за кордоном які
створюють Ось такі освітні центри великі
п'ятиденні школи які теж мають намір і
дуже хочуть укласти з нами договір про
співпрацю щоб ми могли
власне на виході забезпечити дітей
документами про освіту Ну я сподіваюсь
що дуже сильно з міністерством освіти
вдасться реалізувати і заключити
договори з новими партнерами так само ми
плануємо вести координаційну діяльність
наших діток які навчаються в школах
України дистанційно надаючи підтримку
різного характеру методичну інформаційну
і консультативну ми плануємо
координувати
новостворені українські освітні хаби за
кордоном так само координація діяльності
українських культурно-освітніх центрів
за кордоном забезпечивши За можливості
власне і
підручниками і
консультативною допомогою різними
дидактичними дидактичними матеріалами
методичним продуктом наразі планується
створення такого інформаційного
кол-центру до якого може звернутися
наші громадяни України за кордоном які
які цього потребують для надання
безпосередньо інформації
про напрямок про напрямок руху плануємо
плануємо підписання договорів Скажімо
так процедуру підписання договорів з
школами партнерами
організаціями через Міністерство
закордонних справ
щоб потім Ну не було різних Скажімо так
маніпуляцій і різних
питань також хочемо повернутися до
проекту повернення
проведення зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання Скажімо так практика така вже
була
разом спільноко-українським центрами
оцінювання якості освіти
проведення ЗНО за кордоном
І
власне теж потребуємо потребуємо і
плануємо розвиватися в технічному плані
Дякуємо в цьому році забезпечені
35 одиниць нової комп'ютерної техніки
Міністерство освіти передало дуже за це
Дякуємо тому що скажемо так техніка
старіє і необхідно працювати йти
в ногу з часом так і у нас також
планується
ведення нової навчального
адміністративної платформи нової
двоцифрового середовища Через яке буде
власне проводитися як і адміністрування
по школі так і процес консультації та
оцінювання екстернів Я сподіваюся що
наші діти повернуться додому за кордоном
і продовжать навчання в Україні
Слава Україні
[музика]
пані Олександрові зараз надаю слово
маргариті носковлій дякую Дуже дякую
дистанційна Вітаю колеги з прийдешнім
першим вересням але ми завжди збираємося
на те Який досвід ми здобули в
попередній рік і дійсно попередній рік
був дуже тяжким ми опинилися перед
викликами яких освіта України Ще не
знала Я думаю європейська освіта також і
власне
досвід дистанційного навчання
періоду ковіду він вже був нерятівним
але він став лакмусовим папірцем який
показував наскільки школа школи
просунулась вперед для того щоб
здолати нові виклики дякую пані Тетяна
якщо ви мені допоможете з презентацією Я
хочу сьогодні представити вам досвід
школи яка була утворена на початку війни
це був волонтерський проект українська
дистанційна школа яка народилася на
теренах Львівщини е-е це Спільний проект
ідея Департаменту освіти і науки
Львівської військової на той час воєнне
Перепрошую е-е обласної адміністрації та
центру інноваційних освітніх технологій
Національного університету Львівська
політехніка Як бачите
[музика]
на слайді в період від ідеї до початку
навчання минуло два тижні ми стартували
по суті 1 березня коли просто від ідеї
від необхідності допомогти дітям які
приїжджають до нас на львівщину на захід
України для дітей які опинилися за
кордоном для тих дітей які були на
окупованих територіях і залишалися в
зоні активних бойових дій треба було
організувати навчання і ми не спочатку
про це ми думали тільки про дітей які
навчалися на Львівщині але я так показав
оцей двотижневий марафон до нас
записалися
1729 дітей і 122 вчителя виявили бажання
на волонтерських засадах допомогти цим
діткам ми стартували на власних
приватних так ресурсах І от я хочу
показати що в нас було через місяць ви
бачите діаграми перший діаграмка - це
учні розподіл учнів по регіонах які
знаходилися де вони вчилися до початку
війни Як бачите 45 і трошки більше ніж
45%, це були Харківська область і
Львівщини там було 7,8%. а якщо ми
подивимося на діаграму поруч то ви
бачите де перебували діти на момент 15
квітня в навчанні і знову ж таки
Харківська область тоді ще не було так
багато
просування
перед
окупантів наших так ворогів але чверть
знаходилися на Львівщині понад
19% знаходилися перепрошую 18% за
кордоном і по різних областях України
знаходилися наші діти навчалися вони в
різних умовах і ми розуміли що треба
було організувати дуже гнучке навчання
яке дозволило би їм навчатися і
перебуваючи в обосховищі і перебуваючи в
місцях переміщення осіб за кордоном і
дітям які жили в школах які приїхали на
захід України тобто все це
впливало на особливості організації якщо
можна на наступний слайд
тим не менш на 15 червня
2022 року день коли закінчився
Навчальний рік у нашій українській
дистанційній школі ви бачите розподіл по
класах де скільки в яких класах
навчалися у нас учнів за цей період
Звичайно вони не всі завершили навчання
власне 15 червня у нас в школі всього
794 завершили але
3293 учні
спробували і вчилися у нас хоч і
наголосити що показником
ефективності навчання якщо можна назад
назад у нас кількістю оцінок які здобули
Наші учні 47
490 всі вчителі які навчали теж були
здивовані тому скільки це було виконано
роботи і кожна ця оцінка була
прокомендована і надана допомога
наступний слайд власне продемонструє
відгуки
батьків і самих вчителів Я Хочу
наголосити власне на досвіді вчителів
тому що для них це був виклик це були
вчителі які працювали в своїх школах і
паралельно надавали послуги нашим учням
те що більшість цих дітей вирішило
продовжити навчання в українській
дистанційній школі показує якість
навчання І власне педагогічний колектив
який зібрався якщо можна наступний слайд
питання яке мені завжди задають як це
стало можливим я вам чесно скажу ми не
знали що ми зможемо це і мабуть 1
березня коли ми розпочинали роботу Ми
навіть не уявляли який
Пласт Так ми зрушимо з місця і скільки
викликів постане перед нами і в першу
чергу я хочу якщо можна так
я Хочу наголосити на тому що це був не
випадковий процес це був тривалий процес
в співпраці
державних установ
місцевої влади власне Національний
університет Львівська політехніка який
змогли забезпечити оце поєднання
підготовки студентів так у нас в
університеті Львівська політехніка існує
єдиний в Україні поки що спеціальність
яка готує за Магістр за магістерською
програмою викладачів дистанційного
навчання це був власне центр яким я
керує якщо можна так ми стали базою для
курсів підвищення кваліфікації з питань
дистанційного навчання ми здійснюємо
навчання 99% дистанційно вже впродовж 5
років власне за оцими технологіями і
база практики для
студентів і для вчителів які могли
відпрацювати ті технології і
консультативним центром в першу чергу
для Львівщини власне назад якщо можна
я постараюсь швидше розумію час
результатом було те що впродовж останніх
двох років у нас реалізовується
Стратегія і програмі розвитку освіти
Львівщини окремим рядочком розвиток і
підготовка вчителів і закладів освіти до
дистанційного навчання і одним з таких
проектів був проект Moodle Це просто
який передбачав комплекс модель
підготовки школи з нуля під ключ для
розгортання і організації навчання Яке
дозволяло використовувати дистанційну
платформу в школі середовищі дистанційне
незалежно від форми організації учні
змішані дистанційний сімейний
індивідуальне неважно Головне що це був
ресурс який дозволяв працювати якщо
можна наступний слайд
і ось хочу подякувати величезній команді
вчителів які я впевнена в нашій школі
працювала 75 вчителів волонтерів але по
Україні їх було значно більше тисячі і
дякую вам за те що ви робили але
зверніть увагу Хто вчився хто вчив наших
учнів у нас волонтером були директори і
завичі і керівників відділів освіти
територіальних громад і
аспіранти випускники кандидати наук але
особливістю було вперше в чергу те що Як
бачите 87% вчителів це були вчителі які
брали участь у проекті motel це просто і
Власне вони забезпечили оцих
двотижневими миттєвий процес і
організацію якісного навчання і все це
супроводжувало п'ятеро людей які
адміністрували і забезпечували всі
технічні сторони наступний слайд Я вже
стараюся швидко власне
цей процес показав і нові прогалини нові
проблеми які оголилися власне завдяки
війні трошки дивне звучання але все ж
таки саме завдяки ми побачили теми Чим
ще варто працювати Міністерство освіти
створило робочу комісію робочу групу в
якій ми працювали дуже плідно Ось і
власне результатом були і рекомендації
щодо удосконалення положення про
дистанційне навчання і методичні
рекомендації які от пані Тетяна
представляла моделі можливих варіантів
навчання учнів Я впевнена що ми зараз
опинилися перед ситуацією коли треба
дуже багато документів що переглянути
доопрацювати зробити щось у нас тут не
працює через хвилину виключиться але
важливим є те що ми можемо
і маємо вже досвід позитивних
масштабування позитивних практик
реалізації якісного дистанційного
навчання в межах України і за кордоном І
це свідчить дуже багато речей власне і
Львівська політехніка от з цією моделлю
проекту Model Це просто готова до цього
долучитися
контакти нашого центру і наступний слайд
історія і контакти української
дистанційної школи яка ліцензована і
продовжує свою роботу на волонтерських
засадах вчителі продовжують роботу з
учнями вже перших 11 класів Дякуємо
успішного і легкого емоційно і
результативного навчального року тому що
наші успіхи - це поразка наших ворогів
Дівчата я вам дякую дякую
пані Маргариту хочу ще подякувати від
всіх батьків і колег освітян за те що
західна Україна
прийняла так багато
і здобувачів освіти і колег саме з
окупованих територій Це було дуже
важливо щоб ми всі разом відчули себе не
викинутими з цього процесу освітнього
програму всі разом Саме так єдності сила
Ну що ж ми продовжимо Я хочу нагадати що
всі презентації які сьогодні будуть тут
представлені будуть також доступними для
всіх наших глядачів хто і охоче Ну що ж
зараз з радістю передаю слово Юрію
Демидюк і Олені Артема
Доброго дня шановні колеги назвами
презентації освіта для перемоги цифровий
контент швидкі рішення та перспективи
розвитку а освіта і перемога недаремно
виділені у Великій літери
для нас дуже важливою є перемога і слава
нашим збройним силам завдяки яким
в деяких в більшості областей України
буде змога розпочати
повноцінно-освітній процес
але
важливі також і знання тому що завдяки
знанням і завдяки здобутій освіті ми
спритніші
ловкіщі
за нашого ворога і ми обов'язково
переможемо
перейдемо власне до самої презентації
Український інститут розвитку освіти які
є представляє є адміністратором
всеукраїнської школи онлайн
станом на серпень зареєстровано на вшо
це скорочена назва 450 000 користувачів
це і учні і це вчителі з понад 9 000
закладів загальної середньої освіти це
понад 60%.
але під час воєнного стану було
дозволено і технічним адміністратором
використовувати ресурс вшо без
реєстрації і завдяки цьому кількість
унікальних користувачів збільшилась
понад в два рази і зараз становить
близько мільйона унікальних користувачів
А що стосується кількості перегляду це
понад 5 млн переглядів у 140 країнах
світу Ну очевидно що це не лише особи
які змушено переселились за межі України
через повномасштабних вторгнення а це
просто наші земляки українці і
представники діаспори
Ну тут коротко е-е
представлено
відеоконтентний вшо - це курси для 5-11
класів є можливість для мікронавчання
розміщено відеоконтент завдання для
самоперевірки
підсумкове тестування але залишається
чутливою темою
контент для початкових класів і
я трошки наперед забігаючи анонсує що
має колега з інституту модернізації
змісту освіти буде представляти ті
Заходи які були вжиті і міністерствам
імзо для того щоб ми знайшли той
найкращий контент для початкової школи
для того щоб певний контент було
розміщено на всеукраїнській школі онлайн
треба відповідати певним критеріям і
керівництвом освіти затверджено наказ
номер
затвердженого порядок наповнення
платформи Ви що наказом номер
1067 чому я Звертаю увагу на цей наказ
тому що і в часи пандемії і в часи в час
повномасштабного вторгнення дуже багато
наших колег освітян практиків
знайшли в собі талант здібності
творити цифровий контент і відповідно до
порядку наповнення платформи кожен
освітянин може подати свої матеріали на
розгляд експертній раді яка скерує на
експертизу а далі справа буде за
українським інститутом розвитку освіти з
тим щоб от оприлюднити цей освітній
контент
власне Ця процедура
вказана дуже важливо пройти всі
необхідні експертизи для того щоб всі і
е-е вчителі які використовують контенції
української школи онлайн і батьків які
е-е
використовують в шоу для того щоб
допомогти дитині здобути освіту були
впевнені в тому що цей контент дійсно
якісним безпечним і наочним
повертаючись до контенту для початкової
школи
хочу трошки повернутися назад і сказати
що платформа створена за державний кошти
і той матеріал який зараз там міститься
це теж за кошти державного бюджету але в
умовах скорочення бюджетного
фінансування у зв'язку з війною в
зв'язку з тим що збройні сили потребують
фінансування
питання зараз контент створюється за
рахунок наших міжнародних партнерів
величезна їмка і контент контент для
п'ятого шостого класу переважно зараз
створюється завдяки дитячого фонду ООН
юнісеф за рахунок фінського проекту і ми
розраховуємо що восени цей контент
з'явиться пройде всі всі експертизи і
буде корисним всім дітям вчителям і
батьками але також є певні вимоги до
контенту для початкової школи і якраз
та організація яка створює контент для
старшої школи за підтримки
голландської організації Word Child
створює цифрові застосунки для дітей
початкової школи чому це
важливо якраз за рахунок цифрового
застосунку е-е відповідно до концепції
е-е щодо курсів для початкової школи
дуже важливим є
якраз для дітей молодшого шкільного віку
сфокусувати на іграх і на ігровізації
процесів
особливі вимоги до інтерфейсу до до
смартфонів потрібно залучення батьків і
інша інші вимоги до до сповіщень інші
технічні вимоги є важливими вже зараз
якщо ми будемо говорити про
інклюзивність всеукраїнської школи
онлайн то є наявні є наявний транскрипт
до кожного уроку
транскрипт усного мовлення вчителя і
зараз поступово розміщується до кожного
уроку
аудіо дискрипція для учнів з порушенням
зору
завдяки вишивав Вчителі можуть
індивідуально адаптувати тексти для
легкого читання учнів використовувати
інші
додаткові ресурси засоби для підтримки
учня
і власне теж я анонсував виступ своєї
колеги з інституту модернізації змісту
освіти хочу анонсувати виступ моєї
колеги яка буде колеги з українського
інституту розвитку освіти вона буде
виступати на секції яка стосується
цифровізації в сфері освіти якраз буде
презентувати курс який розроблено
українським інститутом розвитку освіти
назва курсу всеукраїнська школа онлайн
для дистанційного та чи змішаного
навчання ми цей курс називаємо промо
курс в США для певної промоції
всеукраїнської школи онлайн з тим щоб
вчителі могли використовувати
ці цифрові інструменти у своїй
професійній діяльності і
тут коротко представлена тематика
цього курсу але раджу всім практикам
шкільної освіти такі переглянути виступ
моєї колеги про цей курс який буде
презентуватись на вже згаданій
секції я вам дякую за увагу величезна
дяка всім нашим колегам всі
представлялися паралельно що вони
вчителі паралельно Я вчитель історії
колеги велика Вам вдячність за те що ми
спільно з вами робимо
Так я підхоплюю виступ колеги пана Юрія
і сьогодні вже звучала теза про те що
дистанційна форма освіти навчання не
втратила своє актуальності На жаль
агресія Росії
воєнна агресія Росії
залишила актуальною і школу
всеукраїнську школу онлайн
єдине що
додалась ще одна потреба охопити
українською освітою дітей які опинилися
на тимчасово окупованих територіях і за
межами України з метою пошуку навчальних
матеріалів про які зазначав вже пан Юрій
для початкової школи і для п'ятих класів
які сьогодні ми говорили приступають до
навчання питання за новою програмою
нової української школи інститутом
модернізації змісту освіти за дорученням
Міністерства освіти було проведено
конкурс огляд
електронних освітніх ресурсів для
закладів загальної середньої освіти
серед учасників конкурсу були учителі
які представляли власні доробки
презентації комплекси дидактичних вправ
навчальні посібники тощо конкурс на
комісія відмітила низку матеріалів які
після певного доопрацювання можна
рекомендувати для використання в
освітньому процесі робіт матеріалів від
педагогів було багато всіх не назвеш
тому
Дякуємо всім за активну участь і хочу ще
зазначити що знаковим є те що учасниками
конкурсу стали і представники соціально
відповідального бізнесу в галузі освіти
були представлені підручники для
початкової школи для перших других
класів математика
я досліджую світ мистецтво для для
п'ятих класів була ціла низка
підручників з інтегровані в курсів
природознавства вони там різноманітні
ключовим критерієм за яким
відбувався вибір переможців Це була
було цілісне цілісне розгортання
навчального матеріалу щоб
забезпечувалася системне викладення
матеріалу
протягом
навчального періоду та Тобто ми
розглядали все ж таки рік більше
віталася
комплексність від першого до п'ятого
класу системність тих матеріалів Ну і
крім того всі матеріали пройшли
науково-методично психолого-педагогічно
антидискриміна
майбутньому оцінку змістової складової
та дизайнергономічно і технічно
функціонального оцінку програмної і
технічної складових переможцями конкурсу
стали 15
електронних освітніх ресурсів що
отримали понад 70% загальної кількості
можливих балів хочу сказати що
результати конкурсу вони вже оприлюднені
на сайті інституту модернізації змісту
освіти і ми сподіваємося що ті матеріали
невдовзі з'являться на всеукраїнській
школі онлайн і будуть корисні для
освітян для здобувачів освіти особливо
ще раз закцентую для тих хто зараз
тимчасово знаходиться не в своїх
навчальних закладах освітніх закладах
знаходяться на окупованих територіях або
за межами України всіх чека російському
в Україні і віримо в це дякую
пані Олена і разом з вашим виступом ми
завершимо
тепер і зараз ми розпочинаємо власне
друзі уроки які стосуються змісту освіти
для будуть представлені навчальні
програми для учнів методичні матеріали
для вчителів рекомендації до батьків і
розпочати наш другий блок Я запрошую
Олега топова та Тетяна тобто називав
карабаша і Тетяна засі
сьогодні який сьогодні з нами які
приєднаються поспіль я хотів би
наголосити на тому що сьогодні вона
масштабна
війна яка йде в Україні і російські
агресори окупанти які хочуть забрати у
нас нашу територію нашу незалежність
нашу волю і демократію і збройні сили
України все роблять для того щоб
охоронити нашу територіальну цілісність
боронити український народ боронити
кожного з нас а ми з вами боронимо
нашого світу і робимо все для того щоб
ми розпочали новий навчальний рік з
підручниками з методичними матеріалами
для допомоги вчителям у процесі навчання
загальні середньої освіти Я хотів би
наголосити на тому що Інститут
педагогіки Національної академії
педагогічних наук України робить багато
зусиль для
навчально-методичного забезпечення
загальної середньої освіти і
модернізації в контексті нової
української школи і якщо ви пригадуєте
2020-21 рік ми експериментально
випробовували в пілотних школах
навчальні матеріали наші програми І
сьогодні ми можемо говорити що
2022-23 новини навчальний рік як
розпочинається з 1 вересня ми можемо
надати
якісь зробили вже і графували відповідні
модельні навчальні програми 23
навчальних програм і 16 підручників які
ми сьогодні представляємо це комплекс
підручників з усіх предметів для п'ятого
класу з урахуванням нашої методичної
системи тому що у нас була розроблена
цілісна Методична система куди увійшли
програми і
наші підручники які формують цілісність
знань і в учнів в разі ми застосували і
системну структурний і інтерактивний і
інтегрований
особистий теорії товарна діяльність і
компетентність не підходи в
контексті і нової української школи в
контексті
державного стандарту базової середньої
освіти
концептуальних програм щодо stem-освіти
щодо природничо-наукової освіти Ну а
також використали ті
міжнародні звіти які стосуються пізно
розроблені Якщо говорити про розлуплення
дидактичний методичної системи ми
врахували і
науково-методичні забезпечення які ми
підготували до нового навчального року і
це говорить про те що вона вийшла на
новий рівень і ми очікуємо нові
досягнення
результативності учень працюючи
напрацювання в модельних навчальних
проводах програмах а також
формування ключових компетентностей і
формування наскрідність умінь які
відповідають і визначені державним
стандартам базової середньої освіти
задля формування читацької навчальної
природничих наукової і математичної
компетентності ми використовуємо методи
активного пізнання і це в розрізі тих
компетентність цих завдань але інновації
наших підручників є те що ми не
показуємо і не даємо готових знань нашим
учням ми це робимо через дослідження
через компетентність і завдання через
проблемні завдання і відповідно у нас
виріс оцей рівень успішності рівень
знаннєвої передагами тому що учні більш
знань термі поняття в законах вони це
починають розуміти а не заучувати І
завчати як було раніше тому ми
говоримо про те що наш підручник це не
просто передача знань А це інструмент
який
передає наглядову інформацію
знаннєву і сукупності цілісності і е-е
системності знань
враховуючи Іще один Фактор інноваційного
такої складової це
ми можемо говорити про освітні портрет
Партнерство і я би хотів наголосити на
тому що є три позиції освітнього
партнерства - це передусім
освітньо-партнерством між працівниками
педагогічними В загальних середньої
освіти які вибирають модельні навчальні
програми разом з підручниками між
вчителями і авторами підручників а також
між вчителями авто підручниками і
батьками і учнями і це говорить про те
що в освітньому партнерському ми можемо
досягти певних результатів вагомих
результатів тому що вони обмінюються
думками вони надають свої пропозиції Які
важливі для подальшого успіху у процесі
навчання Ну і е-е підкріпимо це е-е тим
що ми
напрацювали з вчителями для того щоб
вони впроваджували ці новітні підручники
новітні методики якими підготували до
нового навчального року це е підвищили
кваліфікацію підвищили коагуляцію в
інституті педагогіки понад 21 000
вчителів які з різних предметів які
працювали з нашими
науковими співробітниками і ми ним
давали відповідні рекомендації методичні
поради як готуватися до нового
навчального року Ну і наостанок хотів би
вас запросити всі від 25 серпня у 10-й
годині у національній академії
педагогічних наук України сьогодні
Василь Григорович До речі зробив цю
промову дав уже всі знають ми всіх
Запрошуємо до того що ми будемо
проводити цю е-е конференцію серпневу
Президії Національної академії
педагогічних наук України і ми
підготували Отакі методичні поради про
які ми розкажемо і покажемо на цій
конференції нащо називається конференція
учені на ПН України українським учителям
тому Дякую вам за увагу і дякую за те що
сьогодні ми зможемо донести це до
української освітянської спільноти
Дякую за те що сьогодні ми зібрались
вислугували свої думки обмінялися
досвідом і сподіваюся що новий
навчальний рік почнеться вчасно офлайн
офлайн змішаному форматі але він
почнеться і ми досягнемо успіхів у
процесі навчання Дякую за увагу Слава
Україні
Дякую два слова буквально
Інститут педагогіки апробував все
пілотування 5 класу і ми готові
допомагати і далі і працювати з
пілотними закладами освіти шостих класах
супроводжувати науково-методичний
супровід змін підтримувати реформу і
знаємо навчаючись ви перемагаємо
освітній фронт найсильніший тому всім
нам сили і віри в те що майбутнє в наших
дітях А ми їм допоможемо здобути якісну
освіту дякую дякую за вашу роботу до
слова Запрошуємо пане брат Роман Шиян
представить
вельмишановні колеги Дорогі друзі Я
власне
в своєму слові зосереджуюся на пілоті
але апелюватиму також і до загальної
практики
нової української школи до перспектив
продовження реформи
до внутрішніх викликів реформи нової
української школи як всі промовці
підкреслили сьогодні
додалися виклики ковіду який насправді
триває ми просто його якось не помічаємо
але Нова хвиля здається
відбувається
і війни
тобто яка насправді тривала вже на
момент початку реформи і триватиме до
перемоги
я на початку в контексті цих викликів
спочатку трохи
статистики команда підтримки реформ
спільно з
координаторкою пілоту з Міністерства
освіти Оксаною Коваленко і з нашими
колегами з інституту модернізації змісту
освіти провели опитування керівників
пілотних шкіл в період з 10 до 30 червня
і серед іншого з'ясували що
в опитуванні цьому взяли участь 125 шкіл
з
160 семи які номінально є за наказом
учасниками пілоту але уже поза цим
опитуванням ми з'ясували що реально
зможуть
принаймні мають намір продовжувати свою
роботу в пілоті 145 шкіл при цьому Ми
повинні розуміти що серед них є декілька
на тимчасову окупованих територій в
таких відомих локаціях як Чорнобаївка
Нова Каховка Скадовськ Попасна
з двох
1076 вчителів які
беруть участь в пілоті
змушені були
залишити
територію свого перебування
Про це повідомили 87 керівників шкіл
190 двоє з них
виїхали або виїхали і повернулися з-за
кордону
здебільшого вони мали За свідченням
керівників шкіл змогу продовжувати свою
викладацьку діяльність виняток становить
респондентів 9 респондентів показали що
такої можливості в цих вчителів на
момент їхнього виїзду навесні не було
про учнів з шести тисяч 500 42-х учнів
2169 залишили свої місця свого
постійного перебування проживання і з
них
виїжджали за кордон ну частина з них
повернулися тобто третина учнів мали
обмежений доступ до свого навчального
навчального закладу
і відомі випадки коли внутрішньо
переміщені
[музика]
учні з числа п'ятикласники з числа
внутрішнього переміщених осіб шукали
пілотну школу там де вони опинилися це
свідчить про це може свідчити про їх і
про те що вони цінують це є цей
свою участь власне в цьому форматі
Зараз ми оновлюємо кілька днів тому Ми
надіслали
[музика]
питальник і маємо намір оновити ці дані
бо з 30 червня багато що змінилося 87
респондентів станом на вчорашній день
вже відповіли і я звертаюся до колег
відгукніться будь ласка щоб ми розуміли
загальну ситуацію і могли спільно
рухатися далі
повертаючись до викликів
діти повернуться до зоопарти в будь-яких
будь-який з перелічених форм
і ми повинні
розуміти що
діагностика вхідне діагностування так
зване
зараз теж стає викликом і це воно
по-перше займає набагато більше часу і
очевидно
може спонукати до того аби на його
підставі
скорегувати освітню програму заклад
закладу
навчальні програми
але точно календарно-тематичне
планування і це я хотів би тут згадати
про ініціативу проекту супровід урядових
реформ в Україні
який В яке відбувається за підтримки
уряду Канади вони в співпраці з
міністерством освіти і науки України і
українським інститутом розвитку освіти з
використанням ресурсу
всеукраїнської школи онлайн
готують на вересень
інструмент для вчителів
щодо виявлення надолужування і
надолужування прогалин у досяганні
результатів навчання
і цей процес очевидно буде складний і це
виклик який раніше виглядав Він завжди
існував цей виклик повернути дітей і
з'ясувати чого вони насправді навчилися
але зараз він звичайно стає це
стосується переважно це зараз на
сьогодні це стосується кожного класу але
особливо спочатку кожного циклу це
інструмент про який я згадав з
математики з української для 5 на
початок базової освіти за результатами
початкової 7 і 9 класу ми з ними зараз
комунікуємо для того щоб використати
частину частково цей інструмент і на
рівні шостого класу і в перспективі на
завершення
першого циклу базової освіти
наступний виклик це доступність
навчальних матеріалів
підручники для п'ятого класу здається
вже існує вже досягнута домовленість про
те що вони будуть в електронній формі
доступними для всіх через
офіційно через сайт інституту
модернізації змісту освіти але також
можливо через а сайти
інститут видавців
і разом з матеріалами які створюються на
як доповнення до цих підручників І
також я Хочу наголосити що
в червні на початку червня бо був
відкритий доступ до нового ресурсу який
називається нужхаб який був створений за
підтримки проекту навчаємося разом
співпраці з партнерами з Європейського
Союзу за таким пильним оком колег з
Європейської комісії
які який має три частини і одна з них
присвячена матеріалам нової української
школи Там уже на сьогодні всі ті
матеріали які були свого часу створені
для початкової освіти і от е-е підручник
включно з підручниками е-е є доступними
і
Тобто це таке Єдине вікно доступу яке в
якому яке адміністратив якого будуть
моніторити також те що відбувається в те
що з'являється офіційно на сайті
Міністерства на сайті агенції
міністерських на сайті на сайтах інших
зацікавлених сторін і при цьому Я хотів
би також
наголосити що існує виклик що робити тим
е-е вчителям які обрали свого часу
модельного навчальну програму на цикл
зараз приходять шостий клас А де а
навчальні матеріали за цією моделлю вони
програ тих авторів і тих видавців які з
якими вони працювали в 5-му класі не
з'явилися бо ну серед них були ті хто
демотивував наприклад той конкурс який
відбувся на початку червня колеги не
побачили своєї перспективи в тому щоб
прийти в шостий клас оскільки в п'ятому
не вдалося І хоча я наголошу що деякі з
таких позицій Як От наприклад
інтегрований курс української мови і
літератур колеги все-таки продовжують цю
роботу
бо це справді не легко з такими новими
рішеннями пройти відразу так щоб вчителі
наважилися це використовувати От ну
тобто ми консультувалися і
так виглядає що в більшості випадків Ну
тут ми тут існує три варіанти виходу з
цієї ситуації це по-перше перейти на
подібні моделі навчальні програми в
крайньому випадку
або використовувати наявні наявні
матеріали залишаючись на тій моделі
навчальної програми яка була свого часу
обрана рік тому Ну і створювати власне
навчальні матеріали комбінувати ті
навчальні матеріали які які є які будуть
доступними і я власне тут звертаючись до
авторських колективів до видавців
закликав би ці матеріали робити
доступними ширшому загалумі не лише тим
пілотним школам які їх обрали тому що за
теперішніх умов вони навіть на прямому
можуть використовуватися і на рівні
шостого класу незалежно від того за якої
там програми вони на сьогоднішній день
працюють наступний виклик - це
оцінювання
Я хочу підкреслити що
не існує така тверде переконання усіх
причетних що
оцінювання має здійснюватися за групами
результатів навчання які
виписані для кожної освітньої галузі і
загальними критеріями а далі з'являються
особливості кожної освітньої галузі
предмета або інтегрованого курсу і
з'являються і тут мають необхідні і вони
будуть
рекомендації експертні а також бачення
авторських колективів і видавців які
створювали ті чи інші навчальні
матеріали
ці та інші питання будуть висвітлені в
методичних рекомендаціях окремих для
пілоту
методичні рекомендації загальні
традиційно уже е-е
створення а тут ще допрацьовуються І
також вони будуть обговорені на нараді
керівників пілотних шкіл як
запланована на вівторок 23 серпня
наступний пункт - Це професійний
розвиток
педагогічних працівників
і
від
серії
навчальних вебінарів які були
відбувалися
впродовж травня
вересня
2021 року і до якого були залучені
вчителі пілотних шкіл а також
координатори з інститутів це дипломної
педагогічної освіти
за участю партнерів з Європейського
фонду освіти з проекту навчаємося разом
з міжнародного центру вергеленда Lego
foundation британської ради та інших за
підтримки Міністерства
Іро академії команди підтримки реформ та
інших експертів ми перейшли до
прийшли за те ініціатива була підхоплена
інститутами післядипломної педагогічної
освіти які її
застосували і розвинули
от і от в понеділок цього тижня з'явився
онлайн новий курс який освіторія в
співпраці з міністерством освіти
і науки України почала е-е
е-е експонувати перший урок з'явився в
понеділок наступний з'являється
наступного понеділка і таким чином усі
уся проблематика нової української школи
там буде
охоплена і вона може бути корисною також
іншим вчителям які згодом приєднаються
до е-е до реформи це такий своєрідний
камертон таке
мірило еталонний курс не в тому сенсі що
там буде Істина в останній інстанції але
але в тому сенсі що завжди можна
обговорити те що ми бачимо всі бачать
однаково картинки і тоді можна навколо
цього домовлятися про те щоб про спільне
про спільне бачення про
середньотермінову перспективу очевидно
що
на часі створення модельних навчальних
програм для другого циклу базової освіти
а також
державного стандарту профільної освіти і
впровадження якого невдовзі розпочнеться
І на завершення ще про виклик
інтеграції в європейській освітній
простір я зацікавленням почув послухав
виступи колег пані Олександре з
нетерпінням чекаю також виступу Дарини
сиджу про
яке має стосовно до цього питання бо тут
важливо зберегти зв'язок з українською
системою освіти усіх школярів де б вони
не перебували
на сьогодні чи впродовж наступного
навчального року задля того щоб вони
задля їхнього повернення додому
за найближчої нагоди
це з одного боку а з іншого боку
збереження перспективи
академічної мобільності тому що це теж
цінність яку яку треба
зберегти Тобто ми зовсім не той спосіб
інтегруємося зараз в європейській Союзі
як собі уявляли але
ми завжди схильні шукати
вікно можливостей там де здавалося
просто Нестерпні Нестерпні умови
до цього не дуже спонукають
і добра новина тут полягає в тому що
засадничі положення які є в наших
документах починаючи від державного
стандарту закінчуючи медальними
навчальними програмами А так ключові
компетентності наскрізні вміння
результати навчання все це концепти з
міжнародного європейського професійного
лексикону
Ну і я на завершення скажу що
запорука нашого поступу
Якщо хочете перемога це консультація
нашої спільноти І при множеннішого
професійного капіталу Дякую за увагу
Слава Україні
хочу декілька слів саме привернути до
питання нової української школи а
особливо до те що говорили а колеги З
академії педагогічних наук і
наголошували і про те що ви сказали свої
розмові А про Пілот про пілотування про
продовження нової української школи
для нас для Міністерства освіти це
надзвичайно важливим оскільки є
наступність і для вчителів для
адміністрації шкіл для батьків важливо
розуміти що нова українська школа є
і буде Я хочу я не буду вже пан роман
анонсував про те що 23
запланованого часу уточнюється а нарада
для директорів шкіл
пілотників тобто для тих які пілотування
у 6 класі але Дозвольте лише один
маленький
допис у Вайбері групі для директорів
шкіл я зачитаю і Ви зрозумієте чому я це
роблю а Добрий вечір що вказувати у
формі якщо наш заклад не ушкоджений але
знаходиться на окупованій території з 1
вересня ми починаємо навчання онлайн і
ви знаєте майже таких директорів шкіл
таких вчителів ми це однозначно
Україна є буде
Україну не зламати ми Незламні тому що
люди які знаходяться сьогодні на
окупованій території думають про шостий
клас про нову українську школу вони
будуть навчатися онлайн і я вам дуже
вдячна колеги
за цю підтримку яку ми надаємо саме
нашим пілотникам школам які зараз йдуть
впереді
і шостий клас нова українська школа
Слава Україні
[музика]
але одразу така глибина і ми все це
відчули заради чого ми разом всі
працюємо пані Наталія хочу надати слово
вам
стосовно професійного розвитку педагогів
онлайн та офлайн
Дякую колеги я представляю заклад
післядипломної педагогічної освіти і
Хочу зазначити що під час
випробувань воєнним станом саме заклади
післядипломної педагогічної освіти були
одними із тих інституцій які
показали саме
інвестиційну спроможність і стійкість як
національної так і регіональних систем
світу
під час військової агресії заклади
післядипломної освіти стали не лише
освітянськими осередками але й
волонтерськими і
також
гуманітарними хабабами на виду один
простий приклад що лише за перший місяць
військової агресії працівники інституту
які працювали в кол-центрі 24 години на
добу прийняли 4000 дзвінків І надавали
психологічну моральну допомогу тим людям
які цікали від війни які вивозили дітей
адже Київщина опинилась в Епіцентрі
страшних подій які дехто бачив живу А
дехто спостерігав по телевізору і це все
одно було дуже жахливо і саме в таких
умовах Необхідно також удосконалювати
освітній процес щоб він був комфортний і
безпечний для педагогів поширювати кращі
практики і зокрема в системі
дистанційної освіти
в Київському обласному інституті
середовища дистанційного навчання
створено вже більше 15 років тому і
відтоді система пройшла Випробування
часом
змінами реформами пандемією і наразі
військовим станом постійно розвивається
наповнюється як вдосконалюється наразі
розроблено 45 програм підвищення фахової
кваліфікації які розміщені на платформі
Moodle
за цей час створено потужний навчальний
контент інтерактивні і практичні заняття
від матеріали практику зорієнтовані
завдання тести
пакет діагностичного інструментарію
методичні рекомендації тощо і саме таке
середовище дало можливість забезпечити
навчання близько
1800 педагогів які навчалися як
синхронного так і в асинхронному режимі
в форматі онлайн проведено також низку
заходів спрямованих на розвиток
методичної компетентності
вчителів в яких взяли участь 800
педагогів як керівників закладів освіти
так і вчителів-предметників
в онлайн відбувалося також діяльність і
професійних спільнот загалом більше 3000
педагогів пройшло навчання в 40 днів
підстудії і в 60 майстер-класах і як уже
зазначали попередні спікери Ми не можемо
дозволити щоб агресія Російської
Федерації завадила нашим планам щодо
реформування системи освіти в країні так
у літній період в інституті проведено
онлайн навчання вчителів Київської
області які забезпечують впровадження
державного стандарту
середньої освіти в 5-6 класах також до
навчання долучилися педагоги із 6
областей України
внутрішньо переміщені а також освітяни з
тимчасового окупованих територій
тренерами
були як автори співавтори розробники
державного стандарту автори спів автори
модельних програм освітні експерти
досвідчені і авторитетні в області
педагоги загалом таким навчанням було
охоплено 6,5 тисяч педагогів
реагуючи також на виклики сьогодення і
на запити керівників місцевих органів
управління освітою зараз працюємо над
розробленням програми моніторингу
дистанційної освіти
в закладах загальної середньої освіти
така програма допоможе отримати
Об'єктивні дані виявити та відстежити
тенденції в розвитку якості дистанційної
освіти і розробити чіткі рекомендації
щодо покращення надання освітніх послуг
також на запит педагогів області
авторським колективом інституту було
розроблено програму по наданню
домедичної допомоги і в той час це було
забезпечення до медичної допомоги а
також безпечне поводження на дорозі і ми
провели навчання і більше 100 вчителів
були навчені за цією
програма яка має назву знаємо та діємо
отримала схвалення Міністерства освіти і
науки України
наразі творча група працює над
доповненням до програми з питань мінної
безпеки протипожежної безпеки а також
над розробленням навчально-методичного
забезпечення навчання за програмою
відбувається змішаному режимі є
онлайн-курс а також є треніс формування
практичних навичок по наданню до
медичної допомоги який педагоги зможуть
пройти в класі безпеки в інституті
створена модель такого класу безпеки на
слайді ви бачите зони які там
представлені клас забезпечений
навчальними Посібниками муляжами
аптечками дорожніми знаками засобами
захисту а також матеріалами для
психологічного розвантаження тощо
в межах ініціативи першої леді України
Олени зеленської визначено формулою
майбутнього відновлення держави безпека
та ментальне здоров'я у цьому розділі в
інституті організовано не сказав заходів
зокрема онлайн навчання 62 педагогів
інклюзивно-ресурсних центрів за
спеціалізацію кризову психологічна
допомога а також ми впроваджуємо
проектнів небезпека
що реалізується Також через онлайн
навчання та через практичні тренінги для
300 педагогів і закладів освіти
Київської області і ці заклади стали
можливі завдяки
нашій співпраці з нашими партнерами яких
я хотіла б назвати але за браком часу ви
бачите їх на цьому слайді
і
також
[музика]
нашому порталі в інституті розміщена
детальна інформація для реєстрації на
заходи з дистанційного навчання А також
для реєстрації участі у різних проєктах
і
ми абсолютно переконані якщо ми разом ми
сильні ви переживаємо всі виклики і все
буде Україна дякую за увагу дякую пані
Наталю ви знаєте що Котра ми
продемонстрували що педагоги готові наші
є відкритими гнучкими і адаптивними до
всіх викликів сьогодення І власне на
виступі пані Наталії ми завершили другий
блок який стосувався з міста освіти і
зараз ми переходимо до третього уроку це
є про міжнародний досвід і тому хотілося
почути надати слово Ольга Донецьк
ще раз Всім доброго дня по-перше
Хочу передати вітання від своїх колег І
що Для нас надзвичайно приємно бути
сьогодні присутніми на цій конференції
перед початком нового навчального року
я представляю в центрі мінівенголанда і
трошки розкажу наша досвід роботи в
сфері демократизації українських шкіл А
взагалі хочеться повернутися назад
перший проект центр мінівенголанда був в
2013 році в лас-пі в Криму Це був
молодіжний форум з демократії та прав
людини і до речі
нам дуже допомагала тобі його
організовувати пані Оксана Коваленка і
то це дуже велика вдячність і з того
моменту стартувала наша послідовна і
плідна співпраця
власне про європейські центри
міні-верген та він був створений
радою Європи як ресур центр для країн
членів Правди Європи заради розвитку
освіти з демократичного громадянства та
освіти справ людини
центр має проекти багатьох країнах
членах Ради Європи і хоче звернути увагу
на те що з
початку повномасштабного вторгнення всі
програми і всі контакти які були з
Російською Федерацією були припинені і
призупинені і закриті ці програми були
в Україні
програми працює з 2015 року центри імені
вигравав де працює з 2015 року
коли розпочалася програма демократична
школа підтримка освітніх реформ і ми
дуже щасливі з початком
реформи нової української школи Ми дуже
активно підтримували всі зусилля
Міністерства освіти і науки України а
також разом зі всіма партнерами які
на слайді Ми намагалися втілювати і
інтегрувати реформу вже в заради
демократизації українських шкіл
трошки розкажу про програму на що ми в
яких сферах ми працюємо ми перше це яке
він сказала що ми працюємо заради
демократизації шкільної культури і ми
підтримуємо
підтримуємо спроможність із утилізацію
українських шкіл в умовах автономії та
децентралізації врядування а також
безпосередньо Ми підтримуємо
спроможність педагогічних працівників
які впроваджують нову українську школу
бо ми переконані що реформа вона
відбувається в класі і заради цього ми
організовуємо різноманітні навчання для
обміну досвіду нетворкінгу
Працюємо як з керівниками шкіл їх
заступникам так із вчителями І до речі
теж Ми були причетні роман вже казав щоб
ми були причетні до приготування
які беруть участь у спілкуванні і також
дуже приємно що ми були і є причетними
до розробки нових політик і е-е окремих
документів зокрема ми брали участь
утримували робочі групи за розробки
таких документів як державність
державний стандарт і критеріїв
оцінювання якості освіти а також
організовували навчальні візити то
Норвегії сподіваємося що І далі це
будемо робити І
також Зараз великою частиною нашої
роботи є якраз онлайн навчання Ми
займаємося розробкою різноманітних
інтернет-ресурсів для
педагогів нової української школи
Та взагалі для педагогів України
заради просування реформи
і
якраз хочу сказати що
створений цикл онлайн-ресурсів він вже
працює давно це 30 кроків до нової
української школи навчаємо громадянина
це такий цикл який складається з
чотирьох
онлайн курси це я маса Я маю курси вони
доступні на платформі про метеос вони є
безкоштовними і вже зареєстрованих 80
тисяч користувачів а вже зареєстрований
на цій платформі і прийшли ці курси це
курси стартуємо секрети успішних
директора і директорки курс успішної
вчителювання прості рецепти на щодень
школа та громада для дитини а також курс
стартуємо до успішної школи а Ці курси
вони є як я вже сказала я масовими і
доступне відкрито для всіх вчителів вони
є безкоштовними за проходження
сертифікати підвищення кваліфікації від
18 до 30 годин і
Всі ми знаємо що онлайн-курси перевагу
онлайн курсів є В тому що ви самостійно
обираєте тривалість навчання темп
навчання
і звичайно що вони доступні є
безкоштовними для всіх вчителів і також
таким те що об'єднує всі ці курси є
інтерактивний посібника він теж
доступний на платформі Там є багато
структурованих матеріалів
до яких ви маєте постійний доступ Ну і
власне курс про який хотіли який був
анонсований А це новий новий курс він
нещодавно запрацював теж на
платформі промітелс і звичайно що ідея
його виникла ще після того як ми
спілкувалися з викликами 20-го року під
час
пандемії коли Ми зрозуміли що наших
цифрових навичок відправити імейл або
зв'язатися
по Скайпу або створити документ або
презентацію не вистачає задля того щоб
запровадити освітні навчальний процес
тому Ми зрозуміли що необхідно створити
такий курс який був наступний для всіх
який був інтерактивним цікавим який би
дозволяв нам запровадити цікаве
відповідальне і безпечне середовище для
запровадження навчального процесу
І
про що цей курс на цьому курсі можна
і дізнатися як проводити цікаві онлайн
уроки тому що на ньому дуже багато
різних інструментів ресурсів онлайн
ресурсів які будуть створити навчання
зробити його більш інтерактивним і
цікавим для всіх учасників навчального
процесу
також можна познайомитися з деякими
техніками оцінювання зокрема це
формувальне оцінювання а також як
використовувати як застосовувати ці
техніки у форматі онлайн цифровому
форматі також приділена велика увага
Щодо цієї фейкової там маніпуляційної
інформації
також
цей курс корисний не тільки за вчителів
а для адміністрації тому що там частина
приділена тому як розподіляти
навантаження в цифровому
в просторі як організувати процес
навчання дистанційний і як розподіляти
це навантаження
також
допоможе сформувати таку власну цифрову
репутацію і підвищити її рівень і
засвоїти можете засвоїти правила
кібербезпеки
створення підтримки безпечного
безпечного освітнього середовища
і безпосередньо можете опанувати нові
педагогічні практики і
робити цифрове середовище закладу
цікавим безпечним і відповідальним До
речі тут ви можете перейти по qr-коду
він відправляє одразу на цей курс на
Прометеус можете подивитися вже на
сьогодні зараз реєстрована на курсі 10
000 користувачів то загалом якщо
зарахувати і ті курси то вже 90 тисяч
користувачів
користується оцими курсами взагалі хочу
ще сказати що
курс працює нещодавно але дуже багато
позитивних відгуків тому що
він дуже просто перший Він дуже простий
багато відеоматеріалів на курсі а також
багато
вбудованих курса
цікавих інструментів і інтерактивних
показано як можна використовувати різні
інтерактивні інструменти задля того щоб
організовувати навчальний процес щоб
уроки були цікавими інтерактивними щоб
безпосередньо учні брали в них активну
участь а не були тільки слухачами були
залучені до процесу і серед відгуків
найбільше таких
позитивних відвів набрали це
така вже сказала інтерактивність
матеріалів завдань а також матеріали які
можна застосовувати які можуть допомогти
запровадити оцей
національний процес онлайн
і ще би хотіла сказати що
вже другий рік ми починаємо ми робимо
змішані онлайн курси так званих
називаємо ще фасилітовані онлайн-курсії
якщо ті були масові курси вони доступні
онлайн-платформі і користувачі заходять
і самостійно навчаються а самостійно
проходять Ці курси а унікальність цих
курсів є В тому що є можливість
зустрічатися за авторами курсу і час від
часу відбувається зустрічі там або раз
на тиждень або два рази на тиждень
відбувається зустрічі безпосередньо за
авторами авторками цих курсів вже ми
мали декілька випусків До речі і дуже
цікаво було що цього літа на навіть в
умовах війни а в умовах багатьох
викликів для України Ми отримали дуже
багато заявок на участь в курсах тому що
ми побачили що не вистачає цієї
спілкування навчання для вчителів не
було дуже здивовані що вони готові
продовжувати навчатися
користувачів завершили впродовж літа
завершили Ці курси але курси були
присвячені формуванню
і розвитку громадянських компетентностей
формування розвитку громадянських
компетентностей через учнівський
самоврядування а також курси для
адміністрації школи де директорів від
директорок і заступників про
демократичне врядування
і
на осінь цього року ми будемо анонсувати
ще серію таких фасилітованих курсів які
будуть присвячені Власне цей масовий
курс про який я говорила шкільне життя
онлайн його трансформуємо теж на
фасилітований курс а також буде
анонсоване курси з формувального
оцінювання і розвитку громадянських
компетентностей
найближчим часом будемо анонсувати про
початок нових курсів і Дякую всім за
увагу це наша Facebook сторінка теж
можете долучатися
будемо дуже раді дякую дякую пані Ольга
і хочемо запросити до слова пані Дарино
якраз стосовно підтримки тимчасово
переміщеннях учнів вчителів України
Перемоги
насправді Це перша презентація проекту
тому щиро дякую за можливість розказати
про нього більше і відповісти на усі
ваші запитання Отже проект підтримки
тимчасового переміщених учнів і вчителів
України і трансформація української
освіти для майбутнього справді Це поки
що довга робоча назва але я сподіваємося
ми трохи скоротимо найближчим часом Отже
я представляю кембридський університет і
один з його департаментів це видавництво
та оцінювання кембридського університету
ким рішення
і в рамках нашого Департаменту в нас є
відділ який має назву Cambridge cation
або відділ партнерства в освіті
кембридського університету це
неприбуткова організація
кембрівського університету метою якої є
спів відбувається з міністерствами
освіти підтримка і вдосконалення якості
освітніх систем в усьому світі щоб кожен
мав змогу отримати необхідні компетенції
для розвитку
потенціалу особистості та знаходження
свого місця в суспільстві
Хочу зазначити одразу що на початку
самого початку перших днів війни в
Україні і російської агресії в Україні
університет зайняв дуже принципово
позицію підтримки України і засудження
дій Росії на території України ми
припинили будь-яку діяльність з Росією
та Білорусі і наш
віце-канцевий кембрівського університету
повторює щоразу у своїх промовах що ми
солідарні з українцями не лише під час
війни а готові підтримувати Україну і
після української Перемоги для відбудови
і реінтеграції українських школярів і
освіти і відбудови української освіти у
майбутньому
Сьогодні я тут щоб поговорити з вами про
важливий розвиток
цього партнерства партнерства з
міністерствами освіти і науки України і
мета якого є підтримка учнів від першого
до 11 класу
ми знаємо що війна змусила більше
дві третини учнів покинути свої домівки
і переміститися або в межах України або
за кордоном і по всьому вчителі по
всьому світу вчителі родини громади
організації та країни
інвестують що допомогти українським
дітям продовжити навчання Ми вирішили
надати нашу відповідь
тому як ми можемо допомогти Україні як
посилити співпрацю безлічі міжнародних
організацій урядів партнерства для того
щоб
об'єднати зусилля зробити їх системними
для того щоб наші діти продовжували
навчання будьте
незалежно від зовнішніх умов для того
щоб створити їм фундамент для їх
ефективного повернення назад
мета проекту
зображено на екрані це в першу чергу
зняття освітнього навантаження з учнів
що тимчасово перебувають у інших країнах
і можливість зарахування їх оцінок за
навчання в українській школі за ті
предмети які щоб вони не дублювали
навчання з математики наприклад в
українській школі в онлайн наприклад Чи
у змішаному навчанні якщо вони обирають
а змогли сконцентруватися виключно на
предметах українською мовою української
літератури чи історію України ми
пропонуємо розробити персоналізований
моніторинг поступу навчання це власне
про те що говорив пан роман у своєму
виступі щоб ми могли відслідкувати
прогрес і освітній поступ кожного учня
знову ж таки незалежно від того де вони
знаходяться
допомога із
професійною підтримка вчителів та учнів
допомога із реінтеграцію школярів в
українській освітнє середовище у
післявоєнний період
тому що ми вважаємо що допомагати
потрібно не лише у кризових ситуаціях як
як це війна сьогодні але і допомога з їх
ефективним поверненням назад і
продовженням навчання А також інтеграція
української освітньої системи з
освітніми системами країн ЄС
на жаль так інтеграція відбувається не у
той спосіб як Ми планували але війна є
тим поштовхом до України до швидшого
наближення до освітніх систем і
програм країн Європейського Союзу та
наразі перебувають українці
Отже Ми почнемо з розробки
є три основних складові
складових проекту Це розробка освітніх
карт у країнах тимчасового перебування
українських школярів
я буду зосереджуватися більш детально на
кожному аспекті допомога із фіксування
навчального прогресу кожної дитини
третій чомусь не зображений на слайді
але це власне професійний розвиток
вчителів і допомога із реінтеграцією
українських школярів назад в освітню
систему щодо розпочнемо з
першого Це розробка освітніх карт у
країнах тимчасового перебування
українських школярів
працює над порівняльним аналізом
навчальних програм з математики та
природничих наук у кожній країні яка
приймає українських дітей як відома
кожна країна має різну навчальну
програму і маючи так звану освітню карту
щоб зрозуміти схожість і відмінності між
навчальними шляхами в різних країнах ми
можемо повернути дітям контроль над
їхнім навчальним прогресом та покращення
якість підтримки яку вони отримують Якщо
коротко навчальні програми міститимуть
мапування Я не знаю як правильно це
назвати
приклад відмінностей і спільного у
навчальних програмах країни і
показники де знаходиться український
учень у певній навчальній програмі
країни де вони перебувають для учня це
означає що більший вони отримуватимуть
більший доступ і чіткішу структуру свого
навчального процесу
учні зможуть зрозуміти що організація на
уроці А вчити вчителі знатимуть які теми
вже було вивчено учнем в Україні а які
ще необхідно надолужити і які потребують
додаткової уваги для учня для кращої
інтеграції у навчальних процесах для
вчителя це забезпечує краще розуміння
учнів і вчителі зможуть зрозуміти
здібності знання та навички учнів і
зрозуміти де потрібно справжня
цілеспрямована підтримка і для урядів
країн що приймають українських е-е дітей
а також для Міністерства освіти і науки
України Такі навчальні карти можуть
допомогти у більш чіткому розумінні
прогалин у знаннях і навичках і
підтримують і ще також може зможе
підтримати майбутнє освітню політику та
реформи
друга складова - це реєстрація
успішності навчання кожної дитини це
власне те вхідне діагностування про яке
ви говорили пане Роман
Ми прагнемо забезпечити цифрове
оцінювання знань і навичок українських
дітей переміщених осіб з математики
природничих наук а також їх соціального
і емоційного стану на період у навчання
у країнах тимчасового перебування це
будуть спеціально розроблені тести в
онлайн форматі українською мовою щоб
визначити вхідний рівень учнів на момент
навчання це допоможе відслідкувати
освітній прогрес кожного українського
учня а також зрозуміти вплив емоційного
стану на навчання розуміючи що багато з
учнів бачили жахи війни і їх емоційний
стан безумовно позначається на
успішності навчання для учнів це
забезпечення стабільності та позбавлення
додат кожного зайвого навантаження також
оцінки з цих предметів зможуть бути
зараховані українською школою що
відповідно вивільнять більше часу для
вивчення предметів української мови як
от українська мова літератури історія
України тощо і саме тих які на жаль не
завжди можна вивчати в країнах
тимчасового перебування українських
школярів хоча насправді ми також знаємо
що багато урядів приймаючих країн
організовують українські школи залучають
українських вчителів для підтримки наших
школярів у своїх країнах це забезпечить
впевненість у тому що їхня освіта є
пріоритетом і підвищить їх мотивацію
продовжувати навчання в складних
обставинах для вчителів Це допоможе
краще зрозуміти підтримку яку потребує
кожна дитина в класі і для урядів знову
ж таки це допоможе гарантувати що кожна
дитина не залишиться поза увагою це десь
глибше розуміння прогалин у навчанні та
стане у нагоді Під час планування
майбутньої реінтеграції учнів та
відбудови освіти після
нашої Перемоги
і остання частина проекту - це
забезпечення постійної підтримки
вчителів розуміючи важливість ролі
вчителя у навчальному процесі особливо в
умовах війни
ми вважаємо що
персоналізована робота з вчителями в
цьому випадку надзвичайно буде корисною
і необхідною
як відомо по всій Україні та країнах де
приймають вимушене приміщених
українських учнів вчителі стикаються із
1 травмами учнів а по-друге з обмеженою
інформацією про освітні системи та
високим відповідно навантаженням які яка
ця відсутність інформації створює ми
підтримуватиме цілеспрямований
послідовний розвиток вчителів що дає їм
інструменти які допоможуть учням
надолужити пропущено і піклуючись при
цьому про благополуччя як вчителя так і
учня також прагнемо надати вчителям
інформацію необхідно Для узгодження з
національними пріоритетами щоб вони
підтримували дітей у спосіб які допоможе
їм у довгостроковій перспективі Отже
учні отримують перевагу від викладачів
які є кваліфікованими та готовими до
нових викликів вчителі зростатимуть
професійно матимуть покращене
психосоціальне благополуччя та
довгостроковий професійний розвиток а
урядом матимуть краще кваліфікованих
викладачів для підтримки переміщених
учнів
і незважаючи на те що діти стикаються із
іншими труднощами на шляху продовження
своєї освітньої подорожі в інших країнах
в першу чергу це мовні бар'єри тому що
по-перше не всі ще володіють англійською
мовою на достатньому рівні І не завжди
навчання продовжується англійською яка я
першочерговою іноземною мовою в Україні
цей проект що складається із трьох
частин націлений на сфери які отримують
найбільшу користь від спеціалізованого
цілісного та узгодженого освітнього
підходу і у свою чергу цей проект
охопить і матиме позитивний вплив на
тисячі українських учнів у багатьох
приймаючих країнах і наш довготривалий
вплив який ми плануємо і очікуємо
отримати від реалізації такого проекту
кожен із цих кроків є основою для
майбутнього освіти в Україні
цей інтеграція та безпосередність
якісної освіти та навчання і отримання
важливих даних та доказів для розвитку
освіти які в майбутньому будуть
фундаментом для відновлення системи
освіти післявоєнного часу тому що Усі ми
Сподіваюся розуміємо що освіта також
буде змінюватися в залежності від нових
е-е економічних та політичних умов і
подальші наслідки для допомоги Світові в
досягнення цілей сталого розвитку ООН
тому що Україна наразі є прикладом того
як освіта відбудовується і встає
незалежно від зовнішніх умов незалежно
від війни і ми плануємо поширювати цей
досвід далі для інших країн які ми
співпрацюємо
Отже структура яку ми будуємо сьогодні
не буде прописувати якою має бути
система освіти України в майбутньому але
натомість даний проект може стати тим
об'єднуючим мостиком на шляху дошвидшої
інтеграції українського освіти до
освітніх систем країн ЄС та відкриває
нові можливості реформування освіти
відповідно до викликів часу
і нашими наступними кроками є також
підтримка урядів об'єднання підтримки
урядів донорів і партнерів в країнах де
тимчасово перебувають українці ми
розуміємо що самостійно ніхто ніхто не
воює українці зараз воюють спільно з
нашими європейськими партнерами освітяни
за затримують підтримку від наших
європейських партнерів також від урядів
і ми раді цю підтримку надавати
ми при об'єднуємо і мобілізуємось для
ефективного партнерства і реалізації
проекту наразі він повністю фінансується
кембрівський університетом але ми
працюватимемо для того щоб залучати
донорів та
інших учасників проекту це для
ефективного виконання і я думаю що лише
у єдності і колективних діях Сьогодні ми
наближаємо перемогу України з кожним
днем Дуже дякую за увагу компанія Дарина
Дякую про нагідну на нашому Господу
ну по-перше пропозиція - це
співпрацювати з міністерством освіти
іноді відповідальної національної
академією
це перше а друга от ви говорили про
тимчасове переміщення учнів так і заділи
питання з приводу школи шкіри так от
якщо я зрозумів правильно ваша мапа буде
стосуватися тільки тих е-е
тимчасового переміщених учнів чи разом з
школами конкретно які утворюються зараз
в різних країнах
написання по Першому щиро рада співпраці
насправді ми ми залучатимемо не лише
іноземних експертів Ми раді співпраці із
українськими експертами з тими хто писав
державний стандарт з освітні програми
тому що нам важлива і експертна місцева
експертна думка тому звісно Ми раді
співпраці і будемо готові поширювати її
в Україні по другому питанню Ми наразі
перший етап проекту ми
реалізації його і на розробці мабуть
такої пілотної версії проекту на
прикладі математики порівнюючи її з
програмами математики з програмою
математики у Румунії це як міні
міні-версія
проекту як він виглядатиме в майбутньому
на прикладі однієї країни і одного
сегментного започаткова школа
ми аналізуємо навчальні програми але не
аналізуємо як конкретна школа їх виконує
наразі
державний стандарт ви аналізуєте чи
тільки програму державний стандарт
програми підручники тобто зміст освіти
фактично ви ви е аналізуєте Ну вам до
нас конечно порівня
[музика]
дякую А от питання стосовно змісту
освіти Зрозуміло А от тимчасове
переміщення учнів ви знаєте їх кількість
в різних країнах Чи ви не аналізуєте
який ми працюємо звісно
з міністерством так тому що ми підписали
меморандум пропускаємо буквально
Минулого тижня так І звісно ми отримуємо
вхідні дані Від міністерства освіти і
науки України і зосереджуватиметься
відповідно на пріоритетні країни на цих
країн у вас не є теж да окремо Тобто ви
їх співставляєте Я так розумію
їхати до Міністерства закордонних справ
які нам фактично надали інформацію про
перебування здобувачів освіти в різних
країнах
плоть до однієї дитини деяких країнах
ну власне ми так плавно перейшли і
четвертий блок це питання відповіді будь
ласка дуже гарне рішення тому якщо щось
дуже добре якщо є ще запитання тому що
така нагода у нас була дуже добра і тому
є така можливість тому декілька ще
хвилин прошу
Якщо у нас питань немає то наш порядок
денний вичерпаний і
мабуть дійсно таким нормативом
завершення нашої роботи є те що в
єдності сила і співпраці в тому що ми
сильні ми досвідчені і ми спроможні
подолати виклики які спричинені
теперішнім станом в Україні і в освіті
зокрема тому хочу привітати всіх з
наближають з тим часом Коли ми почнемо
освітній процес коли прозвенять дзвоники
у наших закладах освіти яку яких з
нетерпінням чекають як учні так і
педагогічні працівники так і батьки тому
мабуть отой хештег і який запустив
сьогодні міністр на пленарному засіданні
повертаємося до школи
бабусь за спільними зусиллями ми
повертаємося до школи Ми повертаємося до
освіти і
до роботи до роботи
на завершення звісно хочеться подякувати
кожному кожній з вас завершити тонічну
систему ґрунтовну працю щоб вона була
гідно оцінена на всіх рівнях І звісно
хочеться подякувати всім організаторам і
господарям цього чудового закладу який
нас там надали можливість провести
якісно і комфортно нашу зустріч це Олег
лодовському разом з компанією лінгвіст і
кожному кожні з вас за те що ви робите
Дякуємо все буде Україна